tell us about what you've done with
these films the actual work of creating
Bed Stuy well well we didn't really I
didn't create bed stuy but grief bring
bedside to life okay
I would love I you know I do take credit
for this thing I mean the interesting
thing for me is that you know you look
at this movie and because of this team
because the spike we actually shot the
movie in Bed Stuy I think if we were to
make this movie today we would be in
Toronto or Atlanta or somewhere else so
the fact that we had a team of people
who actually really wanted to shoot this
and thought it was necessary to shoot on
location I think it gives the film the
authenticity that it needed well one of
the things we did was you know we we had
a series of you know challenge me how do
you make a movie and keep it interesting
for two hours and keep the audience
engaged in it visually so between myself
and earnest Dickason you know I you know
there was a lot of interesting choices
there you know for me you know obviously
I had to build the pizzeria and I had to
build the Korean market because those
those buildings were not there but you
know part of the challenges for me as a
designer is how do you sneak color into
a movie that's a realistic film
so obviously the the obvious solution
the obvious use of color was the corner
where the corner man we're sitting where
we use to fire engine red to kind of you
know support the idea of heat in the
film but also if you look at the film do
you know the color the steps are painted
and there's windows painted there's a
lot of subtleties as a lot of use of
color sprinkled throughout the whole
movie and that was my challenge as a
designer to to make those kinds of
choices that not only help tell the
story but also enhance the look of the
movie so the debate was with the
universal about then of the picture
because they didn't like the end of the
picture they they kind of wanted a
uplifting ending you know everything's
okay you know and they were asking you
were asking for spike to do as you know
as his characters Mookie to to do maybe
add and then
dressed to the camera on a stoop in
Brooklyn do you remember that spike hell
no oh yeah they didn't want they don't
want the character to pick up the money
that that sounded thrown at him and I
remember the two of us are coming back
on the plane after showing it to the
studio and they said now he can't pick
up their money and I said now you've
been broken I've been broke I said you
might for a moment say oh you know I'm
not gonna hell with us out but before
you walk away you don't have a job
you're gonna pick up that money and then
and then finally spike came up with the
idea of using those quotes by by Martin
Luther King Luther King and Malcolm X
and and and funny enough is that the
character of smiley didn't exist in the
script and so you look at it and you
think of course he must have because he
was so integral to the whole story and
that and that it came he thread his way
all the way through and and that and
that card he was holding those pictures
turned out to be so important in
wrapping the movie up but that was
really for the end of the movie that was
really the debate you know we always
have the attitude to just make the best
use of what we had not to think about
what we didn't have or who we didn't
have there was a version of this movie
that had a different cast had a
different budget had a different studio
and that quickly went by the wayside
when all those people said no because we
were going to make the movie anyway and
you know bill brought up a really great
point about just becoming the character
and to me as much as the movie is
anchored in a time and place that's so
real it also transcends time and place
and it's very emotional for me to see
the movie and see everybody here but I
also think that this movie is going to
live another hundred and twenty-five
years that's how important it is
and it reflects not just this
neighborhood and that time and place but
what the human race is its flaws and the
beauty of it and I'm just so proud to be
part of this film part of this legacy
part of this history and to thank Spike
for the courage that it took to make it
because it was so on time and artists
are often called on to reflect a time
and place but it isn't very often that
they have the courage to do it with such
urgency and and honesty and thank you
spike and keep it going John